je regardais souvent ce couple qui était
parfait il était l'incarnation du
véritable amour
j'ai envie de recommencer ma vie
je l'aï vu je l'ait vue de la fenêtre du
train
avec cet homme
ça n'a duré qu'un temps ça va pas
est-ce que c'était pour moi ma sauce
vous pouvez me dire où vous étiez
vendredi soir je suis allé en ville
ensuite rendu visite au mur et vous
parlez de votre ex mari
si j'ai bien compris cette femme qui a
disparu et est à nouveau sa lutte à
s'allumer gamme
qu'est ce que tu fais si je suis venu
pour l'aider à retrouver mégane
je crois que tu ne perds ça
j'ai vu votre femme elle n'était pas
seule megan voit un psy c'est ce que
vous avez vu
qu'est ce qui s'est passé cette nuit
donc j'ai lu quelque part que lorsqu'un
train vous heurte il peut vous arracher
tous vos vêtements
vous avez été vu dans les environs cette
ville
avez vous tué mégane bruel non
dites moi ce qui s'est passé cette nuit
là
pourquoi êtes vous là parce que ses
pairs de moi même